the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
alright guys welcome to the the last
official day of 2201 can't believe we've
actually made it here and you guys have
learned a ton about how ionizing
radiation does and doesn't affect
different types of matter if you've
noticed that the whole class has been
kind of taking a slant towards looking
at issues in the public sphere from
things like hormesis to dose to risk to
power plans - today we're going to talk
about food irradiation one of the main
reasons that we have all sorts of
incredibly safe food today thanks to
ionizing radiation a lot of the myths
and misconceptions and science behind
what does and what doesn't happen when
youa radiate food and you guys are fully
equipped to determine not just is food
irradiation safe but how should it be
conducted how should it not be conducted
and what would the effects really be and
where those stuff that we did the last
few class is actually looking up
research papers and discerning which
sources are real and which ones are
let's just say not for lack of a bunch
of four-letter words you can tell for
yourselves what for what sources are
actually worth looking at so just just
quickly go over the basics of food
irradiation and maybe five minutes
before we hit the primary sources so the
general idea here for anyone that got
into the reading which I'll pull up
right here is that we irradiated to do a
whole sorts whole bunch of different
things can anyone tell me what are some
of the reasons one might irradiated
yeah it gets rid of bacteria other
harmful organisms it just kills other
organisms like what like bacteria anyone
else yes insects it's actually used to
either kill or sterilize insects so that
they don't breed and let's say [ __ ] oh
yeah totally because the dose required
to sterilize something is usually a lot
lower than the dose required to kill
something why do you guys think that is
yeah that's right and anyone remember
what those quality factors look like for
those reproductive cells that's right
let me let me bring it up let me go into
the dost of symmetry and background I
think it'll help to actually see the
numbers here let's go to the tissue
quality factors there we go
right at the top of the list
reproductive organs so it takes a whole
lot less dose to sterilize something
like insects or other you know bacteria
or things or I don't know if you can say
sterilized viruses it's still kind of
under debate whether viruses are
technically alive they're right on that
edge of what people would consider alive
or not and there's still a debate going
on about what does a live really mean
but any rate yeah you can sterilize the
insect population for example who here's
bought a bag of rice before and who here
has found some little rice bugs in that
bag of rice before are you serious I
must stop at the cheap store I find them
all the time but the nice thing is if
you were radiate them then they won't
breed and continue to eat and breed in
the bag and then you open the bag and
you've got a swarm of I don't know what
those things are rice weevils there's
something I think I remember looking
them up once because I was like what is
this thing in the rice yeah it's gross
but that's why we do food irradiation
now what else what other reasons might
want to radiate food other than to kill
or sterilize things in it yeah
it does preserve shelf-life especially
of things like fresh fruits vegetables
seeds legumes anyone have any idea why
yeah
yeah one one would be it kills things
that eat it but the other thing is those
plants have reproductive cells as well
and what happens let's say let's pick a
good example
anyone ever had really old really well
sprouted bean sprouts before like not
the fresh ones but the really old ones
not like old like they've sat behind the
fridge or something but okay yeah super
crazy sprouted anyone remember what they
taste like they get kind of bitter and
rather unpleasant so one of the main
reasons for radiating food is to prevent
sprouting and prevent germination
because as soon as the plant sprouts and
starts to say like alright let's grow it
starts to consume its store of sugars
water nutrients and everything else and
start generating other flavors which
tend to be fairly off flavors so another
way that you can keep things tasting
good even if they don't have bugs or
weevils or insects or viruses in them is
prevent them from changing at all
through their normal metabolic processes
so it kind of freezes the food in place
now there's another little since I
mentioned freezing there's another
little caveat to that at what
temperature do you think would be the
best temperature to a radiator food
you think cold and why do you say so
yeah let's bring it up we talked about G
values and temperature and I think it's
a little further and it's in the
chemical effects so I'll jog your guys
memory a bit I'm just a week ago where
we were talking about G values or the
number of different radio lytic
byproducts or radiolysis byproducts that
are formed as a function of temperature
I'm not going to fullscreen that because
it's gonna get all freaky but you can
see that there's a whole lot more of
them formed as a function of temperature
what's not shown here is what happens
when this reaches 0 zero degrees Celsius
what does how it happens to water at
zero degree Celsius look outside what
are we going it freezes okay
all these G values are calculated
assuming the free species are diffusing
in liquid water when you freeze the food
you pretty much shut down diffusion when
you shut down diffusion how do these
chemicals react or not in a different
way can they move to find each other no
they're frozen in place you're stuck at
the diffusion coefficient in ice which
is a whole lot slower than in free
flowing water so in this way you can
kill whatever organisms are there even
if they can survive freezing by directly
damaging their DNA without altering as
many of the foods normal tastes flavors
colors whatever and speaking of taste
slavers colors I want to bring up some
of the pseudoscience couple it didn't
take long to find a couple of things on
the internet talking about how we
shouldn't eat irradiated food and to
that I say well next time you spend five
weeks straight on the toilet you may be
thankful for food irradiation so let's
look to see what sort of things could or
couldn't happen with food irradiation
based on well random internet article
again not a not a useful source but
let's see what they say
damages food by breaking up molecules
and creating free radicals that's true
what's the question we should be asking
though is not does it damage molecules
but what do you think yeah
yeah so one did the damage molecules
have any effect were those same damage
molecules there to begin with and the
other question I want to ask us how much
how much is always the question you want
to come back with when somebody says
isn't it true that radiation does binary
effect causes cancer kills babies
whatever you want you know sure enough
but the question is how much so there's
a second source top ten reasons for
opposing food radiation let's go through
these a little bit one-by-one and look
at some of the references which they're
not all bad so let's see in legalizing
food radiation we did not determine a
level which food can be exposed and
still be safe for human consumption so
let's think about what that actually
means we never hit that ld50 or LD ten
or whatever dose we found that will
cause ill effects in humans I would
argue this is a good thing if we haven't
had any documented cases of people
getting sick from food or radiation then
let's and we already get the effects
that we want like stopping germination
and sprouting killing bad things then
great let's not go higher mission
accomplished let's look at the
references again reference one they
actually give a US Code of Federal
Regulations reference to I dare you to
find what they were talking about
various filings over a period of 17
years I'm not sure I think it might be
something more legit but there may also
be a publication called the Federal
Register I doubt the Federal Register
publication has what's called filings
but these would be more official filings
but yeah they're somewhere in the
archives of somewhere but at any rate
again I would argue that this is
actually a good thing we don't know to
what level food irradiation can harm
people now let's think about some of the
ways in which if done incorrectly it
could harm people without me telling you
ahead of time and this will see who did
a little bit of the reading what sort of
types of radiation do we use to radiate
food and why we have our choice of
alphas betas positrons gammas neutrons
heavy ions etc what would you use and
why yeah so you said presumably ionizing
okay which of these types of radiation
are ionizing what do you mean by
ionizing oh I would argue that every one
of these types of radiation can ionize
as we've seen they can all knock out
electrons or other nuclei but you're
getting at an important point can anyone
help out looks clarify cuz you're you're
getting onto the right track anyone yeah
okay
so you may not want to use heavy ions or
alphas because you don't want to plant
anything in the material are you worried
about implanting helium okay what about
iron I mean let's say you want to use
carbon ions and the food is
Carboniferous that's okay but what about
some of these types of radiation are
quite different from the others when we
were talking about everything from gamma
to charge particle to Neutron
interactions what sort of things might
we look at as criteria to determine
whether or not we want to use this for
food irradiation stopping power so
stopping power which is related directly
to range so let's pick an energy of
around one MeV how do you find the range
of one MeV alphas and food great that's
what I was gonna say to you can either
do the calculations or like most of us
actually do we just run a quick
simulation that integrates all those
calculations so let's do that right now
so we will take one MeV helium or 1000
ke V helium we will approximate food as
water with a stoichiometry of two to one
a density of one gram per cubic
centimeter and let's allow for I think I
already know what the answer is gonna be
ten microns what are we getting for a
range five six microns for alpha
particles in water how well would alpha
particle sterilize food not so let's say
you have a chicken
diameter around 40 centimeters the alpha
particles would penetrate the chicken to
a depth of approximately six microns so
alpha particles are probably out what
else is out based on range alone heavy
ions how far do you think iron ions
would penetrate into a chicken
not far at all let's find out
iron ions I'm gonna shrink the scale to
one micron
we actually kind of did this on the
homework didn't we how'd you guys look
at the range of lighter and heavier ions
so you should get what I'm hoping is
that you'll have some sort of an
intuition for how far ions tend to go in
materials so as you go heavier does the
range go up or down range goes down as
we'd expect we're getting just about two
microns of chicken with heavy iron ions
so what could you do to get those to
penetrate farther hmm yeah so you could
boost the energy so if you were to boost
the energy of the alphas let's see first
of all with our typical range relation
where a range is roughly proportional to
kinetic energy squared how much more
energy where we have to impart to the
alphas in order to get them to the
center of the chicken well let's let's
try and work it out right the range is
that the range was about six microns at
an energy of one MeV and we want to get
to about 20 centimeters let's call that
six centimeters we're just gonna use
this approximation for now and we want
to go from six microns to six
centimeters that is far four orders of
magnitude so how many orders of
magnitude would we need to increase the
energy of the alphas to get through okay
so we'd have to go to let's say a
hundred MeV you said let's find out we
can just check this
so we'll switch back to alphas at a
hundred MeV this is already looking to
be fairly uncommon right but this is
physics so let's find out okay so we're
at about 1.5 centimeters and that's
again because at high energies this
range relation changes to about
proportional to T for really high
energies but so we know we're gonna have
to get to around a GeV alphas in order
to food or radiate chicken that sounds
really expensive yeah the proton
cyclotron at MGH is about 250 MeV and
we're talking an eight or nine figure
installation not worth it to radiate
food what else might go wrong with gez
alpha particles what may you induce yeah
a lot of Bream strong radiation we
pretty much ignored bremsstrahlung of
things like alpha particles and protons
but once you get into the GeV or tera
electron volt range you are gonna get a
lot of bremsstrahlung and shielding
those x-rays is gonna be a mess okay so
let's say we've excluded alphas and ions
for the purposes of physics and we are
left with betas positrons gammas and
neutrons what next
neutrons are expensive you either need a
reactor aspiration source or a little
pulsed fusion device two of which we
actually yeah two of which we have down
the street let's say you had a cheap
source of neutrons leave one of those if
you build it and there's money to be
made than able to know if there's money
to be made they will build it and if you
build it they will come with their
chickens for a radiation why else
physically would you not want to use
neutrons to radiate food they damage
everything that's that's okay right if
they're damaging living organisms more
than the food itself that's okay but
what do neutrons tend to do when they
interact with matter and that's as
general or specific as I can make the
question so far the correct answer is
everything
like what Chris
yes so that's when I said you're getting
on the right track so thanks you guys
for doing a teen tag answer yes they can
activate things at pretty much any
energy for example for this I'm gonna
jump to Janice like I said I'd like to
do things live so show you guys that we
can do it on the fly and respond to your
comments in real time it is showing good
okay so this is a skill I want to make
sure that by the end of this class which
is about thirty five minutes from now
you guys will know to jump to Janice and
start looking for the right cross
sections because you're gonna need it
for the rest of your life career time at
MIT pick probably two out of the three
if you guys are going to be nuclear
something's I'm definitely in a
different database right now I was an
incident proton data for other things
that we've become apparent soon let's go
back to incident Neutron data we'll use
the same database that we've been using
all the time the end if most recent
database look at the cross-sections and
let's assume you had some iron in your
food you're a radiating red meat nickel
copper iron pretty common isotope of
iron could be iron 58 let's now go down
and find the Z gamma the neutron capture
cross-section for iron 58 it's decidedly
nonzero at all energies which means
you're going to make iron 59 what
happens when you make iron 59 I don't
expect you to know but where do we go to
get the answer wall yep Tyree that wall
the table of nuclides whatever you want
or the you know the Brookhaven table
whatever you want the point is the table
of nuclides let's take a look at iron 59
see what it does it is not stable it has
a half-life of greater than 10 days it's
a beta emitter and it beta decays to
cobalt 59 which is a stable isotope so
you would be creating an ingestible
source of beta particles nasty stuff
let's see what those beta particles
would do they have about a 1.5 MeV
energy let's look at the decay diagram
there are a few transitions the most
likely of which would give a beta and a
gamma the most to likely of which would
give a beta and a gamma
so you'd be ingesting a duo beta gamma
emitter now to find out how far would
those betas go as and are they energetic
enough to escape you or not what do you
use shrim done do electrons well I
haven't back to calculations over I want
to show you guys there's a database for
everything and it's always on NIST in
addition to I wonder if any of you guys
have found these for the homework
because I didn't use them in the
solutions but they're quite useful NIST
has a database called East are stopping
powers for electrons where you can
simply say graph the total stopping
power or arrange for electrons in
elements or materials materials let's
call food as soft tissue they don't have
that let's go to water it gives you the
range of electrons in grams per square
centimeter in water what do we have to
do to make this into an actual range in
centimeters
multiplied by density or yeah I'm sorry
divided in this case so you have the
range in grams per square centimeter if
you divide by density you're left with
centimeters on the top the density of
liquid waters about one so in the case
of water you can simply read off this
table if you're talking water at 25 C so
a beta particle with an energy of about
1.5 MeV has a range of about a
centimeter in material not something
you'd want to ingest because around one
centimeter away from wherever the betas
end up they would do a whole lot of
damage at the end of their range where
they have the highest stopping power so
we for many many reasons the not least
of which is activation neutrons are out
so we do not irradiated with neutrons
because they will induce radiotoxicity
so for anyone that tells you oh don't
you stick food in a reactor to a
radiator the answer is definitely not
you don't want neutrons nearby so we're
left with different types of betas and
gammas from our study right here we just
found out that betas penetrate about one
centimeter into materials at 1.5 MeV so
how energetic do we have to get them to
get to the center of the chicken
if range is proportional to T squared
and our range at 1 MeV or 1.5 MeV is
about one centimeter if we want to go to
20 centimeters about how much at more
energetic do we have to get the betas to
radiate the whole chicken
okay let's go with ten times let's go to
15 MeV and we can just read off this
chart at 15 MeV we're getting on about
now keep in mind this appears to be a
double log scale so that right there is
10 that right there is a hundred yeah
we're getting towards 10 centimeters if
we want to see where it is at 20 the the
log marker line is kind of missing but
it comes to about here if we go down
we're getting around 30 or 40 MeV how
reasonable does that sound for a linear
accelerator fairly it's not unreasonable
it would still be big yeah I may not be
efficient so we may not use betas to
irradiated tire chickens what if you're
radiating strawberries that are roughly
about a centimeter in diameter
how does a 1 MeV Linux sound we've got
some of those yeah we've got a 2.5 nez
Linux
just down the street building in 40 so
that's totally okay you could use betas
in order to array D 8
thin enough foods food for which you can
reach the center with the range the
betas do you induce any significant
radiotoxicity how do you find out
you could run an experiment or what
database would you jump to to try to
figure this out yeah I would jump to
Janice let's go back there let's see if
they have the incident electron data yes
incident electron data the x-4 database
it's good for charged particles let's
look at iron-56 let's say you're
radiating red-meat this is just total
cross-section so that's not gonna tell
us much it's also not loading and had an
error
I had another very interesting all right
let's see if we have any other
interesting isotopes that have any good
reactions yes not all right well that
any rate it's awfully difficult to
induce radiotoxicity with betas there's
another one I didn't get into which
would be protons somewhere between
alphas betas in terms of range and such
does anyone know perhaps anyone that
works in the vault what happens when you
give very high-energy protons
indeed a lot of gammas and neutrons the
gammas maybe no problem at the radiation
facility the neutrons big problem so
find it again we head to Janus look at
the incident proton data
I've already scoped this out and I know
it's on the X 4 database cross sections
let's go right back up to our iron 56
let's assume we're a radiating red meat
what sort of reactions do we have proton
comma n something with a few points to
it aha a nonzero cross-section so
typically in the range of 5 to 10 MeV
high-energy protons will start to create
neutrons where a proton will come in a
neutron will come out so you would
absolutely not want to use protons above
let's say a safe limit of around 3 MeV
then the problem is what's the range of
3 MeV protons and stuff anyone have a
intuition for that pretty small you
don't know generally the order of
magnitude will head back to here dis rim
will use 3 MeV neutrons or 3 MeV protons
it's looking about a millimeter of
material we're getting about 200 microns
in not useful enough to be useful for
any sort of food irradiation so protons
again are out for reasons of both
neutron activation and range
sure but what energy are the protons
that you're making
I highly doubt you were sitting there
during 10 MeV yeah so 2 to 3 MeV those
proton cross-sections jump to zero in
fact let me show you that for a better
up I'll kill this RIM thing because
that'll fry the computer let's look at I
don't know carbon where there's a whole
lot more data natural carbon there
should be lots of nice cross-sections
here so in goes proton maybe not for
natural let's do carbon-12 has over a
hundred different reactions something
comma end wow there's a lot of reactions
to sort through well I don't want to
waste your time with that now but anyway
hopefully the cross-sections I showed
you show you that around 5 MeV or so you
do start to make neutrons so if you
could get up to 10 MeV that's why the
vaults got that four-foot thick door you
don't want to be in the room when that
happens
yes but the class accelerator go only
goes up to about 2 MeV yeah
and that's perfectly safe to be standing
around there for yep because of
interlock but not because of physics
right ok fair enough
cool so now we're left with gammas
gammas work pretty well they have very
very long ranges even the concept of
range of a gamma is kind of a funny
thing to say because they undergo
exponential attenuation so you want
either a high enough flux of gammas that
they're low attenuation won't matter or
you use a lower energy gamma ray
so cobalt-60 or radiators that give off
those one and a half MeV gammas are
quite commonly used for this sort of
thing because the one and a half MeV
gammas will get through just about
everything you just need a whole lot of
them has anyone here seen or heard of
the cobalto radiator
downstairs in the basement of building 6
we've got one of these things actually
it's just a seared sealed source of
cobalt in the way you start a radiation
as you simply open the door and the
radiation stops being shielded enough
now what things could go wrong with
gammas with super high-energy gammas
ionization is what you want right you
want to ionize the water and the DNA of
the bacteria or the germinating cells so
that they get destroyed what else could
you induce with super high-energy gammas
that's another form of ionization right
so that's a good one
why don't I show you a quick thing let's
go to incident gamma data
I think the x/4 database will be pretty
good let's go back up to iron again
we'll go with our red-meat example gamma
comma Neutron anyone heard of gamma
induced a neutron ejection high enough
any high enough energy gamma rays will
actually cause neutrons to be emitted so
gammas are a definite yes from the point
of view of physics they're also gonna
have to be less than about 5 MeV because
once you get to around 5 MeV or in the
case of iron-56 10 MeV you end up with a
non zero and actually fairly significant
like point 1 barn cross-section for a
gamma goes in a neutron comes out and
that Neutron comes out at whatever
energy it activates what's nearby and
makes all sorts of nasty isotopes that
decay the way they will you guys
remember too from the neutrons
discussion about photo fission the idea
that a gamma ray can induce fission of a
heavy nucleus so if there's any traces
of uranium in the food which there
always are whatever what you don't want
it to do is then make a whole bunch of
fission products because even a couple
parts of mid parts per million of
uranium which might be no big deal could
be a big deal if you turn it into
fission products instead of plain old
uranium where it's just a heavy metal
like lead whatever now we can deal with
a tiny bit of letting our food totally
yeah okay so while looking through these
internet studies talking about I don't
like this kind of are
for irradiation encourages filthy
conditions I don't think that's a fault
of the irradiation I think that's a
fault of the people who are like oh cool
physics means that we can relax our
standards these are separate arguments
and going through all these things that
frankly either our false are true but
the question is how much and are true to
such a small degree that it barely
matters in wading through a lot of these
resources or these uh these things let's
say PhD thesis articles in the ecologist
a lot of other you know FDA papers
various filings yeah from the 60s came
upon actually a really useful document
this World Health Organization study on
the wholesomeness of food irradiated
with doses above ten kilogram it's
modern it was done by a peer-reviewed
study group it was commissioned for a
major organization so I pulled it up
yeah it's like okay there's a legit
reference in here I recommend you guys
look through this it's quite fascinating
how many studies have been done on
rather higher radiation doses so you can
usually get away with stopping
germination at around a gray a kilogram
so rather low dose of radiation the
highest dose anyone would use is about
50 kilogram agna to dose that we use for
food irradiation and looked not just to
say are there ill effects but what are
the ill effects what are the other
compounds that are made and do they
matter in the end and i want to walk you
guys through a few of the bookmarks that
i found pretty fascinating i asked you
guys about gee values at low and high
temperature here's a great plot showing
that right there
this is food irradiation done at 20 and
minus 40 Celsius to look at the amount
of ammonia nitrates ferrocyanide x'
things that you might not want and look
at the difference between a radiating at
20 °c and minus 40 see enormous why is
that so physically exactly diffusion
stops when you cease to have a liquid it
doesn't stop completely
but the diffusion constant of anything
in a solid it's gonna be a whole lot
slower than that same anything in a
liquid and so this way you can destroy
the cells without all of the radio lytic
byproducts going around and damaging
other food molecules and other food
cells then we got into the question of
off smells and funny sorts of changes so
one of the comments said can change the
flavor odor and texture of food pork can
turn red beef can smell like a wet dog
vegetables could become mushy etcetera
etc etc this study or this review of
studies actually looked at what
compounds are formed in which foods and
by how much the only thing they didn't
tell you is how do they smell so I
looked up a few of those they looked at
hexanes as a function of fat content for
a rather high dose for 10 kilogram or at
least here everything is in normalized
per 10 kilogram so this is the yield of
this compound in nano grams per gram
does that sound like a big deal it may
not sound like a big deal but a lot of
these odiferous compounds are detectable
by the human nose and parts per billion
so they actually do matter and I looked
up to see what sort of smell do hexanes
typically have the word was petrol ik
smelling like petrol or gasoline
might not necessarily be something you
want and it is true that fat compounds
when you break up these uh let's say fat
molecules which usually contain 3 fatty
acids those fatty acids themselves are
very aromatic you've heard that
expression fats where the flavor is
right a lot of it does not just do too
well if you just eat butter not that
flavorful anyone ever tried I'm glad I'm
not the only one okay good but where
real where fat really comes into play is
when you heat it and it undergoes all
sorts of different chemical reactions
with the food nearby liberating some of
the fatty acids it's part of why lamb
smells like lamb and nothing else is
that's not just what that's where the
flavor is a 90% of flavor is smell you
only got five or six tastes I think
that's still under debate but you can
smell thousands of different compounds
and so they actually matter so I started
looking at some of the other ones heptad
echod I mean in micrograms per gram fat
per 10 gray for foods containing a lot
of linoleic acid the smell carrion
beetle sex pheromones the sex pheromone
shouldn't be what turns you off it
should be the carrion beetle what is
carrion it's the beetles that feed on
rotting meat so this is this is the
juice that rotting meat beetles secrete
to attract other rotting meat beetles
nearby to use polite language it's
probably something that you don't want
in your food or is it does anybody know
what makes pork smell like pork is what
you're gonna find out who likes full who
likes pork here awesome I'm gonna ruin
your date there's a compound called scat
toll can anyone figure out from the root
of the word yeah anyone ever heard of
that wonderful barnyard e smell from a
cut of free-range pork anyone heard this
term before it's raise your hands anyone
heard the nice pork barnyard e smell
okay couple people that barnyard e smell
is parts per trillion or parts per
billion of scat toll so you know tiniest
littlest bit of poop yeah the same sort
of compounds that you find in scat in
incredibly small amounts contribute to
the wonderful flavor of really good pork
so just because these compounds are made
in higher do't in higher amounts with
higher amounts of fat or dose doesn't
mean that they're necessarily off of
flavors but there is kind of hilarious
to see what you know what other places
do you tend to find high concentrations
in these the next one down hexa Beck a
train from a radiation of muscle the one
paper I could find that talked about
this in a cocktail of smell compounds
comes from the odiferous defensive stink
glands of read something beetles yeah
sounds horrible right so if you stopped
there you might think great so radiation
produces odiferous defensive stink gland
compounds but as we know pork smells
great we don't necessarily know in what
concentrations have to what is it
hexa deca train would smell good or
smell bad to the human nose it's just no
telling there's some compounds in any
amount if you can detect them they're
terrible there's some compounds that go
from bad to good there's some pounds
that go from good to bad
anyone ever smells someone that's
slopped on perfume before would you
describe the smell as good no but you
know perfume relies on lots of different
compounds in very very small
concentrations is supposed to be subtle
and enhance your own body chemistry
you're not supposed to smell like a
perfume factory explosion so another
sort of real-life analogy where too much
of a good smelling thing can smell
really bad
yeah and so then going on from the
various odiferous compounds where a few
other points I wanted to own oh there's
another one okay seems like the
production is pretty much linear with
either dose or with the abundance of the
precursor normalised a dose this one you
tend to find in deodorants what was the
name of this compound propane die all
died palmitate don't know the structure
cuz I'm not an organic chemist but
things you might find in deodorant again
no telling whether or not this would be
good or bad in food and how much that's
always the question I want you to
remember if somebody asks isn't binary
effect bad you know isn't metatag binary
effect bad the question is depends how
much yeah
they do it shows the dose normalized
yield per 10 kilogram in micrograms per
gram so it shows that depending on how
much of whatever precursor in this case
enzyme and activated muscle there was
how much relative amount of this
compound existed what these graphs are
telling us is they're pretty much all
linear and they're pretty much all the
same for I saw that as human for a
second holy crap it's hard to skip the
beat ham beef chicken pork oh man hey
anyway going into the conclusions which
again are strikingly different than the
internet article would have you believe
I wanted to point things out interesting
irradiating moist foods while frozen in
the absence of oxygen significantly
decreases overall chemical yields by
about 80 percent so it's interesting you
can radiate something to 50 kilogram
minus 30 C and it does the same chemical
change as tenkill agree at room or
chilled temperatures but you do that
much more damage to the organisms so in
this case yeah there you go better to
radiate at cold temperatures and there's
a few other interesting conclusions
these radio lytic compounds are they
found in food otherwise virtually all
the radiolysis products found in
high-dose irradiated foods are either
naturally present or foods or produced
in thermally processed foods before food
irradiation you had heat sterilization
in fact we still do for quite a bit and
folks a lot of times we'll talk about
the amount of nutritional decline the
amount of lack of nutrition from
irradiated foods and they'll just say
it's a bad thing that's not the right
fact to see here food preservation tends
to lower the nutritional content and
there's a neat table a few neat tables I
want you guys to look at in terms of
macronutrients do you lose the protein
the fat the carbohydrates from in this
case gamma-irradiated mackerel as a
function of dose does anybody see a
trend here
take a sec look at the numbers mm-hmm it
does seem like the nutritional content
goes a little bit up with small doses
doesn't it would you necessarily believe
these data at first glance at face value
what's missing from this data set for
you to draw a statistically significant
conclusion arrow bars right we don't
know if this is the graph of let's say
protein content versus dose in gray and
this is protein the data appear to do
something like this if the error bars
are like that then you can't draw any
meaningful conclusion so one would have
to go back to the study to see hopefully
they actually had error bars in their
measurements but so what I can conclude
from this is macronutrients basically
don't change with up to the highest dose
of radiation that we give to any food at
all what about the micronutrients what
about things like vitamins they do go
down somewhat and they're pretty linear
they're fairly linear with dose it's not
much to be disputed there is yes a
radiating food does destroy some of the
vitamins and not the minerals
why wouldn't gamma irradiation destroy
minerals in food what's an example of a
mineral that you need for a survival
iron calcium
yeah a bunch of other elements or
inorganic compounds
why does food irradiation not affect
mineral content
that's right yeah you stay below 5 MeV
gammas and there's literally no change
in the elemental composition of those
minerals the vitamins however tend to be
more complex organic compounds that can
be damaged and one of those big ones is
thiamine better known as vitamin b1 so
irradiated food is a little bit less
nutritious but they give a pretty good
explanation let's see I think that's
later in the conclusion so we'll get to
that conclusions on nutrition yeah there
we go so in this case what they're
saying is well yeah it takes away some
thiamine but irradiated food does not
constitute the major source of thiamine
in the diet so even though it does
reduce the amount of radiation or the
amount of thiamine that you get it
doesn't make a dent in your overall
nutritional uptake unless you eat
nothing but that irradiated food does
anyone remember when the last case as
scurvy in the u.s. happened talking
about single food diets have been right
here at MIT it was awhile ago I think by
now it would have been over 10 or 15
years ago there was a student that
decided I'm gonna have the cheapest food
budget ever and live off nothing but
instant packs of ramen now this is
already a nutritional nightmare but it
got worse and worse so it was the ramen
the flavor packs and water and that's
just what this person ate the whole time
and then they decided you know what I
don't really need the flavor pack
because that's just a bunch of sodium
taking out whatever little
micronutrients were left and then the
next logical step was why bother cooking
it and a few weeks later a massive
constipation and scurvy ensued which is
a disease you don't see anymore from a
deficiency of vitamin C so if you're
only eating one food to begin with you
got other problems that have nothing to
do with food irradiation yeah
I'm not surprised at all either I feel
like this is this is the place I'm
surprised Soylent wasn't invented here
but seems like the kind of thing that
someone here would have done yeah anyway
let's take a look
ah irradiation versus heat sterilization
from a nutritional viewpoint irradiated
foods are equivalent or superior to
thermally sterilized foods why do you
guys think that might be indeed so you'd
actually get some macro nutrients to
disappear if you start to denature or
break down those and even for micro
nutrients the idea here is that the
amount of micronutrient content will go
down roughly linearly with dose what
happens when you reach the temperature
of destabilization of those foods yeah
all of it goes away once it's
temperature unstable if you if you keep
it at that temperature for long enough
you'll destroy pretty much all the
nutritional contents so if the choice is
between do you heat or do you were
radiate a radiating does less damage in
the end and who here as well let's say
anyone here ever had an MRE a meal ready
to eat how do they taste
and they're not great but they do last
for like decades yeah
like many decades is an entire channel
on YouTube of this guy that just eats
MREs from further and further back I
think he's made it as far back as a
civil war 1/8 actual moldy hardtack from
the Civil War but my point here is that
all the way back is definitely to World
War 2 and perhaps beforehand MREs were
sterilized with heat you put something
in a metal and plastic lined bag to keep
out all other organisms you heat it for
long enough to kill every single other
organism and they last for decades and
the question is do you want to eat
what's in the bag usually just if you
want some fun between studying for
finals listen to this guy's reactions
they eat some of these 60 or 70 year old
MREs from World War two or the Korean
War I don't know for attention yeah
anyway well in at any rate canned food
you can tell has an awfully different
taste to it a lot of these cans are heat
sterilized they're pasteurized and the
heat themselves generates a lot of
off-flavors that you can tell the
difference between fresh and canned
green beans right in taste texture color
machinists whatever other qualifiers you
give to food so to those opponents of
food or Asian radiation I'd say consider
the alternatives either heat
sterilization or spending most of your
waking hours in the bathroom
yeah you can't necessarily a lot of
these there are also spores of bacteria
that are incredibly heat tolerant so you
can't necessarily sterilize meat without
cooking it so the best thing to do is to
cook it right sealed in a can or sealed
in something and then don't unseal it
until consumption type yeah there are
other things that you can sterilize
without cooking them like milk milk is
pasteurized you heat it to a temperature
that's sufficient to kill most of the
microorganisms not to sterilize it but
to increase its shelf life so that it
takes months instead of hours for that
microorganism population to bloom and
ruin the milk I'm sure everyone here
smelled spoiled milk before right
doesn't matter how pasteurize it is does
anyone open a carton of expired milk
after its shelf life and yeah that was a
study in two-phase flow right liquid
solid yeah yep so there's some proof
right there a few bacteria survived it's
the same thing with food irradiation you
need an enormous dose in order to
actually sterilize the food so this is
usually the only option for folks with
extremely compromised immune systems and
hospitals is if you want to give them
actually sterile food that's actually
palatable you were radiated to like 50
kilogram and that kills just about every
single organism including the long-lived
spores one other side benefit of food
irradiation is the cells that survive
have been blasted by radiation they tend
to be a lot weaker and more sensitive to
heat and pH and temperature heat
temperatures the same thing so that the
cells that make it through the food
irradiation are more susceptible to
damage and then it helps make things a
little bit safer
I'm trying to see if there's any other
conclusions oh yeah the old who cares
about thymine it's unlikely however that
the irradiated foods of this type would
constitute a large enough proportion of
the diet to compromise the dietary
requirement for thiamine and this is
coming from the World Health
Organization if there's any organization
you think you can trust
about health everywhere it's it's the
who these guys and I don't think we have
time for more of the conclusions however
I will post this document up to the
learning module site so you guys can
peruse at your leisure along with the
bookmarks unless I've done it already I
want to open it up the last two minutes
to any questions you guys may have about
anything including final logistics how
it's gonna roll calm down the review
session on Friday whatever you guys want
yep
the review is 9:00 to 10:00 or 10:30
whenever we finish on Friday I'll email
out with a room once I secure one yeah
there are gamma radiation facilities
where they've got these cobalt 60 or
cesium sources no this would be
processing centers yeah you wouldn't I
mean you can't own can't normally own
one of these giant COBOL sources so
these would be specialized processing
centers yeah oh no it can be done for
foods grown within and for the
consumption in the US too if you want to
extend its shelf life by small or large
amounts you can do it for anything but
there are a number of different types of
produce that can only be imported
because of food irradiation one of these
that I was delighted about was
mangosteens from Thailand mangosteens
probably almost no one here has ever
even heard of her seem surprised anyone
has they're usually okay - Wow - that's
a record they're usually only found in
south or Southeast Asia they don't tend
to last very long and they tend to be
riddled with parasites about one time
out of two that I've opened up a
mangosteen a whole bunch of bug started
crawling out you'd imagine that the US
doesn't want that imported into here but
in 2005 Thailand started or radiating
their mangosteens they were approved for
sale in this country and you can find
them at H Mart now down the street even
food from Hawaii has to be irradiated
for consumption in the continental US
why do you guys think that is
according to the USDA Hawaii is
effectively a different country when it
comes to the sorts of parasites you'd
find in the food it is a part of the US
but it is not a Greek ultra Li a part of
the continental US it's got its own
unique parasites and pathogens and
organisms and critters so a lot of
things coming from Hawaii have to be
irradiated for consumption in the
continental US so yeah food irradiation
helps food commerce go around any other
questions
yeah no it's you I don't know what
percentage of food gets irradiated
especially depend on the type there's
some things that don't need it there's
some things that do need it I'd I'd
wager a guess to say that more imports
get irradiated than domestic consumption
stuff but I don't know that for sure
you